Bartimos Celtigar: Your cause owns a power
that has not been seen in this world since
the days of Old Valyria. Dragons.
Daemon Targaryen: We have Syrax, Caraxes and
Meleys. Baela has Moondancer.
Rhaenyra Targaryen: Daemon,
none of our dragons have been to war.
Daemon Targaryen: There are also unclaimed
dragons. Seasmoke still resides on Driftmark.
Vermithor and Silverwing dwell on the Dragonmont,
still riderless. Then there are the three
wild dragons, all of whom nest here.
Rhaenyra Targaryen: And
who is to ride them?
Daemon Targaryen: Dragonstone
has 13 to their 4.
Bartimos Celtigar: There has never lived a
Stark who forgot an oath. And with House Stark,
the North will follow.
Daemon Targaryen: We have no
friends among the Lannisters.
Borros Baratheon: The House of the
Dragon does not seem to know who rules it.